The Species Comparison tool allows you to
compare human pathways with other species
to see what is common to both or perhaps missing
in humans or in the model organism.
Species comparison is launched using the ‘Analyse
Data’ button in the Pathway browser header
bar or the Analyze button at the top of the
Pathway Browser.
In the Species comparison section, select
one of the species in the dropdown list.
Click the ‘Go’ button.
Reactome uses the manually curated human pathways
to computationally infer their equivalents
in other species.
This inference process is based on gene orthology,
using the Ensembl Compara database.
Biological processes are remarkably well-conserved
over large evolutionary distances.
Even though our focus is to annotate the molecular
details of human biological events, we can
use protein sequence orthology relationships
to ask whether the human proteins involved
in the reaction have orthologs in the model
organism.
If the orthologs exist in the Ensembl Compara
resource, we computationally infer the corresponding
reaction for the model organism and in this
way build up a predicted pathway knowledgebase
for the organism.
Clicking on pathway nodes displays the relevant
pathway diagram.
The colour of reaction objects indicates the
result of the comparison:
o Yellow indicates that the protein has an
inferred equivalent in the comparison species
o Blue indicates that no equivalent was identified.
This protein may not exist in the comparison
species
o No colour indicates that inference was not
possible.
This is always the case for small molecules,
DNA and other objects that have no UniProt
entry
o Objects with bands of colour represent complexes
or sets containing more than one molecule.
The bands of colour reflect the inference
success for the molecules within the complex
or set
o The species comparison bar at the bottom
of the Pathway diagram can be used to turn
off Species comparison colouring.
To see the Species comparison results for
the components of a complex, hover your mouse
over the object and open the information panel.
Traditionally, reactions in Reactome represent
events that occur within a single generic
human cell.
It would, however, be useful to classify reactions
into different human tissue types, as to provide
an evolving picture of the reactions and pathways
in different cell- and tissue-specific environments.
This tool allows users to understand the pathways
that are enriched in different human tissue
types based on protein expression data.
Tissue Distribution is launched using the
Analysis button in the Pathway Browser header
bar.
In the Tissue Distribution section, select
the one experimental tissue dataset [HPA (E-PROT-3)
– Expression Atlas] in the drop-down list.
We have imported protein expression in different
cell or tissue types from the Human Protein
Atlas (HPA), overlaid these proteins on Reactome
data, and extracted the subset of reactions
for that particular cell type.
The HPA data reflecting the expression of
the protein-coding genes in 44 different human
tissues can be visualized through the Analysis
tools.
Once the window refreshes, select the ‘Available
Tissues’ in the left panel and hit the ‘Add’
button to add tissue expression data to the
analysis tool.
Press the “Add All’ button, if you would
like to adjoin all the tissue expression data.
Use the ‘Remove all’ and ‘Remove’
buttons to delete tissue expression data from
the filter list.
Once you have selected all the appropriate
tissues, click the Go button to start the
analysis.
An over-representation analysis is performed
on the protein expression data of each tissue
type.
The results of the Tissue Distribution analysis
are presented similar to that of over-representation.
Users can use the slider at the bottom of
the diagram panel to toggle between the selected
tissue types.
The Analysis tab in the details panel contains
the enrichment statistics and the diagram
panel displays reactions or pathways with
overlaid tissue-specific expression data.
There are several options available to export
analysis results in various formats.
The Downloads button is located at the left
of the Analysis tab in the Details panel.
The following files can be downloaded.
o Complete or filtered analysis results in
CSV format
o Complete analysis results in JSON format
o Identifier mappings of submitted data and
selected resource used for analysis in CSV
format
o A detailed report of the analysis for top
25 most significant pathways in PDF format
o A list of submitted identifiers that were
not found in CSV format
Analysis results overlaid on pathways and
reactions can also be downloaded using the
Export button in the Diagram panel.
This feature takes a screenshot of the current
Diagram panel, which can be saved in PNG,
JPEG, SVG or PDF formats.
Analysis results on the voronoi pathways view
can also be downloaded using the Export button
in the page.